I want you to think
about the image that you see
when I say one word:
migrant.
You may have pictured
a crowded boat in rough waters,
people clinging
to the top of a freight train
or crossing a desert
wearing worn-out shoes.
This is what we see in the news cycle,
24 hours, day after day,
story after story.
People who are desperate, fleeing wars,
fleeing climate change, fleeing poverty.
But in reality, most people
move for more common reasons:
to get a good education, to find a job,
to find family members or to fall in love.
And this is nothing new.
Archaeologists like me
have been studying migration
and finding that people for hundreds
and even thousands of years
have been moving around the globe.
From Europe's earliest farmers
to Vikings to pirates,
Roman gladiators
and even Neanderthal cavemen,
and people like you and me.
Mobility is one of the things
that makes us human.
People move.
And we know this because of something
that you brought with you here tonight.
You carry it with you to many places:
to work, to the gym, to bed,
and even in the shower.
It’s not your cell phone,
and it's not in your purse
or your pockets.
It's you. It's your body
and your bones, all 206 of them.
I brought mine and in case for some reason
you didn’t bring yours along,
we do have an extra one here
because your bones will tell
the story of your life,
even a single tooth.
And we know
that teeth tell us many things.
For your dentist, for example.
He or she can see if you floss
or if, like me, you really like candy,
and you might end up with some cavities.
And if my dentist is here tonight,
yes, I will see you Monday.
And I've been very good.
But your teeth also tell you
something about migration.
If you take your tongue
and run it along your incisors,
these front teeth,
the back of those will be flat
if you have European or African ancestry,
if you feel a sort of scoop
or shovel shape,
your ancestors may have been
Native American or migrated from Asia.
If we go inside the tooth
to the pulp cavity,
we may be able to extract the DNA
and see if your ancestors came
from Egypt or England or both.
But we're not interested as much
in your family's
migration history as yours.
And that's where we
go to the tooth enamel,
what it's made out of,
to try and find out if a person moved
and even when they moved.
And it's based on one simple idea:
that you are what you eat.
All the minerals
and the elements in the food,
like calcium, oxygen,
which is the O in H2O,
sodium and salt,
can tell us something about your diet.
So we know if you like
cornbread or white bread,
if you prefer pork, chicken
or if you really like seafood.
There are other elements
that tell us where that food came from,
and that includes sulfur,
strontium, oxygen and even lead,
which, of course,
you don't want very much of.
But these tell us
where the food comes from
and that can tell us where you were
when you were eating it.
And that is what archaeologists use
to identify ancient migration.
If we look inside the tooth enamel,
we can see, for example,
in your first molar --
this is the one that was forming
along with your baby teeth,
but it's the only one you still have --
and that tells us
where you were living as an infant.
If we look at the wisdom tooth,
which is the last tooth to form,
that enamel would have been mineralizing
just before you hit your teenage years.
So we know where you're living then.
If we look at your bones --
and in that pause,
you just formed some new bone cells --
that’s telling us what you’re eating
and what you’re doing
in just about the past decade of life,
so we can really track where people moved.
And we've looked at this
for hundreds and thousands of individuals
to identify migration in the past.
So I'd like to introduce you
to some ancient migrants.
If we go back in time 1600 years,
we can go to the city of Copán,
where the Maya people lived
in what's now Honduras.
If we came around the year 400 AD,
we might have walked into broad plazas
under a really hot tropical sun
that was shining
onto bright red-painted buildings
that had altars and carved statues
in front of them.
If we'd come on the right day,
we might have seen the inauguration
of ruler K'inich Yax K'uk' Mo',
roughly translated, that means
Sun-Faced First Macaw.
The Maya rulers had really great names:
Bird Jaguar, Dark Sun, Lady Great Skull.
But what was really neat
about Yax K'uk' Mo'
is that he established a dynasty
that lasted for more than 400 years.
And every depiction
we have of him, as you see here,
shows him in foreign clothing.
This is what people wore
in central Mexico,
which was not in the Maya region
and actually hundreds of miles away.
So for a long time, archaeologists thought
that this was a foreign king.
But his teeth told a different story.
By sampling his first molar,
his wisdom tooth and bone,
we found that he, in fact, probably came
from somewhere in the Maya region.
So he was a migrant,
but he may have lived in multiple places
before coming to live at Copán,
even though he dressed
like he was a foreigner,
someone from Mexico.
And I always think about when
the Chicago Cubs were in the World Series
and people went out and bought Cubs gear,
even though maybe
they'd never been to Chicago.
It's a good look.
But let me take you to another Maya city.
And this is where I work,
called Xunantunich.
In 2016, archaeologists found
the largest tomb ever discovered
in the country, in Belize --
that's where Xunantunich is.
And inside that tomb,
there were the remains of a ruler,
but also jade,
the kind of plates and the kind of vessels
that you might see in a museum,
and jaguar bones, which symbolize
possibly royal power.
This person may have actually
even been wearing a jaguar pelt cape.
But Xunantunich was a fairly small city.
So there was a possibility
that this was a foreign ruler.
But in fact, looking at the DNA
and looking at the tooth enamel,
this was no foreign king.
She was a Maya queen
or some other royalty
who was probably local.
We actually don't usually find
foreign kings and queens.
But I told you the story
was about migrants.
And it is, because, in fact,
it was the commoners who moved.
Up to 25 percent of the population
of every village and every city
consisted of migrants --
men, women and children
who'd moved, sometimes
from multiple places,
to live in the same household.
Migration seemed
to be common among the Maya
and many ancient civilizations.
But we can move forward in time
to the year 1493,
when Christopher Columbus
set off on his second voyage
to establish a trading outpost.
He left with 17 ships and 1,200 men,
nobility, clergy, sailors and craftsmen
to establish what
we now know as La Isabela,
named after Queen Isabella,
in the northern part
of the Dominican Republic,
or La Española, as they called it then.
Things were not good:
food was scarce, disease was rampant
and Columbus may not have been
the best manager,
so mortality rates were high.
And by the 1980s and 90s,
when archaeologists began
to excavate the settlement
and then the cemetery,
they started to wonder:
Did the ships’ rosters include
everyone who is buried here?
Who actually lived at La Isabela?
My job came a bit later
as a graduate student
when I was tasked
with going around the island
to try and collect samples that could
serve as proxies for human teeth.
What would the enamel look like
of the people who were
living at La Isabela?
Someone else got to go to Spain,
but I rented a car, drove around,
went into the mountains,
drove toward the river valleys.
And of course, I went to a beach or two.
And everything was going really well
until the last day when I came
to what was supposed to be a bridge
and saw a river and a herd of cows.
So it was getting dark.
I was by myself. I was low on gas.
And after I saw some cowboys
on the other side of the river
kind of waving their hands,
I just rolled down the window
and gunned it.
And I made it across
and I had the samples,
which was a good thing
because there were some surprises.
We did find soldiers
and people from Spain, probably Andalusia,
where Columbus sailed from,
and maybe other parts
of the Mediterranean.
But we also found
an indigenous Taíno woman,
a local one,
and other women who came from Europe,
and one person who,
if we can get some DNA
to see if this is actually true,
may have been from Africa.
None of these people
were on the ships' rosters.
Teeth can tell us things
that the history books leave out.
Our final story brings us
back closer to Mississippi
to an abandoned cemetery
just west of Jackson,
where we can learn
about the lives of the settlers
who lived here in the early 1800s.
Now, some of them came with wealth.
They could erect tombstones and write
their life histories on their graves.
If they were married,
whether they had children,
where they came from
and sometimes even how they died,
as cholera and yellow fever epidemics
swept through the region.
Richard lived until age 56.
He died in 1849.
Charles had a shorter life.
In 1855, he'd survived only to age 29.
But these men were planters,
and we know that they brought
enslaved people with them.
Where were they buried?
And what about the poor farmers
and the sharecroppers?
There were more than 350 graves
in the cemetery.
And so we decided to do our best
to solve these historic forensic cases
and reconstruct the lives
of the people who lived there.
And one of these people,
one of the migrants,
was a man buried in grave 3.
He was of African descent.
He lived into the middle,
maybe even old age,
by the time he died in the early 1900s.
He was probably born into slavery.
And so we wonder,
was he brought to Mississippi?
Was he taken from his family
like so many enslaved children were?
Or did he come after the Civil War
to make a new life for himself,
or find family?
He and the men
with similar life histories,
migrants who are buried
in grave 18 and grave 219,
they made a good enough living
that their families were able
to give them nice burials,
maybe even expensive ones.
So even if we can't say their names,
we can at least tell something
of their stories.
And migration is part of my story, too.
My grandparents came from Germany.
My grandpa in 1923, to join his uncle.
And my grandma a few years later.
We just found their travel documents
and a picture of my grandma
on a lounge chair
on one of the big ships
that sailed across the Atlantic.
We actually don't know
exactly why they came,
but I imagine it's for the same reason
that people come today
to the United States:
because they had a hunger and a hope,
if not to make life better for themselves,
to do it for their kids.
They met in Chicago, got married
and had two boys, one of those was my dad.
I’m the third generation of my family
to be here, and I’m also a migrant.
I've come less than 10 years ago
from the Midwest to live in Mississippi.
So whether your family has
an ancient migration story
or whether you look
in the mirror and see yours,
remember that every time
you smile and show your teeth,
you're sharing that.
Thank you.